we
why do humans explore well you know part
of it is is quite fundamental to our
nature there's there's adventure and
challenge in it but for me the the
reason I'm drawn to exploration is
because it forces us to think in in
novel ways and as an inventor I love you
know going into extraordinary
environments and finding ways to do that
more safely more effectively developing
ways to extract better science and so
for me it's actually been a wonderful
catalyst for innovation similar to
NASA's history you know when you think
back to the Apollo program which is sort
of the icon of my childhood the thing
that I wanted to be a part of as a kid
the things that had to be invented to
safely send astronauts first into Earth
orbit and then to the moon the list is
is so long but what came of that are
extraordinary list of technologies that
we now take for granted for example the
heart monitoring capabilities called the
halter monitor that we now have in daily
practice around the world that was
something that was driven out of
necessity we needed to monitor the heart
health needed to make sure that the crew
was still alive onboard those early tiny
capsules so by pushing our capabilities
whether it's up in space down in the
Antarctic inside volcanoes underneath
our oceans we have to develop new
technologies that benefit all the rest
of us in our daily lives and so the
world is still very very unknown and
what I mean by that is yes we've been to
many most parts of our globe but now we
have a whole array of new sensing
capabilities new technologies new
analytical capabilities big data
analytics that will allow us to go back
to these places and extract more
knowledge and impress our capabilities
more so I think it's an incredibly
exciting time to be alive and certainly
as an explorer through the course of our
space program and our space explorations
thus far we've developed the tools
and encounter measures to safely send
astronauts colonists to faraway worlds
and so as I've already alluded I think
it's it's our human destiny to to go
beyond earth to hopefully create a an
outpost on the moon similar to what we
have the South Pole that where we could
conduct deep-space research and also
create a waypoint to resupply spacecraft
that could travel further on to Mars and
in other exciting places in our own
solar system
may have heard of Enceladus or Europa or
Titan these are ice encrusted moons of
our outer planets that have geothermal
or volcanic activity within them and so
they're actually ice crusted oceans and
wouldn't it be amazing if we could send
a spacecraft and/or crew there and
sample those waters and I would think
that the likelihood of finding at least
some simple life forms there is quite
high that would change everything to
realize that you know life is perhaps
not as unique as we we thought I think
deep space exploration is a human
imperative you know understanding our
place in the solar system and in the
broader universe and one of the exciting
things that's happening right now is
we're discovering these exoplanets
surrounding far away star systems and in
fact planets are probably not the
exception but probably the rule
there are probably planetary bodies
around every little you know star
twinkle twinkle little star that we see
in the night sky and so it's incredibly
exciting to think about what might be
out there is there life elsewhere and I
think if we if we just think about it
statistically the trillions and
trillions of star systems and in faraway
galaxies and the incredible number of
planets that they're certainly out there
the conditions for life must certainly
exist and so I'm excited about the
prospect of sending
hopefully cruise first to the moon but
then on to Mars and I'm really so
excited about Elon Musk's kind of vision
of colonizing Mars doc T's got designs
to build rockets that we carry a hundred
colonists at a time and taking them to
to live out the rest of their lives on
on Mars in fact he's a pretty
interesting guy as I'm sure you know
he's been successful at pretty much
everything that he has set his mind and
his money to do but he's so dedicated to
this kind of concept of colonization
that he's stated that he wants to die on
Mars and I think that's commitment I'm
really passionate about virtual reality
and in fact mixed or augmented reality
in the future ways in which we can
interact and and learn and train
ourselves to do new things from very
remote places and it allow us to
actually control robotics and do things
that we would never be able to do in
person because that environment is is so
dangerous so the human machine interface
is actually something that is part of my
my daily life now I'm CEO of a tech
startup company called fluidity
technologies that is based on my
intellectual property robotic controls
leveraging machine learning so we're
able in a single hand with our
controllers to operate drones
potentially even helicopters and RVs
computer games computer-aided design
augmented reality and maybe even tell
operation of surgical robots and so in
my far away view what I'd love to be
able to offer the world is a surgeon
here in New York City being able to
operate with one of our controllers and
deliver the same high-quality care to a
patient in sub-saharan Africa or in
rural Nepal that sounds like science
fiction but it's it's really quite
attainable with the the technologies
that I see on the forefront
[Music]